sur cette franche explication s'ouvre
borsalino un film que jacques deray
réalise actuellement à marseille dans
les lieux quartier remis à la mode de
1930 et à propos d'un certain milieu
c'est pour les beaux yeux de lola
autrement dit catherine rouvel que les
deux mauvais garçon personnage
interprété par jean paul belmondo et
alain delon viennent d'en découdre mais
le film présente d'autres particularités
je crois que marseille était une ville
très importante actuellement aussi mais
particulièrement en 30 en tout cas sur
un certain plan et je pense que s'ils
seront content de les trouver cette
cette équipe d'acteurs particulièrement
remarquable mais j'attire l'attention et
je fêterai je suis très précises sur ce
décor des années 30 sur ce décor de
marseille c'est pour ça que par exemple
dans ce quartier où nous sommes qui le
quartier du panier
nous avons reconstitué un café d'époque
ce qui est plus commode pour nous pour
profiter de ses rues à s'expliquer il
est impossible de retrouver ailleurs
je pense que marseille devrait avoir la
même place à la fiche que belmondo et
que delon pas tout à fait un film
policier comme les autres c'est un film
policier dans la plus pure tradition
française c'est pas un trailer américain
c'est un policier français avec quand
même une
une histoire d'amitié l'histoire c'est
gai seniors d'hommes et très vives
croatie jean-paul maternelle de dire qui
comprend une somme unique dans le fond
c'est trop facile je trouve d'avoir
belmondo et de long dans un film dans
une histoire qui se passe en 1969 d'un
gangster banal comme un de nos jours
donc je crois que l'intérêt de la chose
c'est justement belmondo et de long en
capella